Parasites have a nasty reputation - but is
really fair to fear these little guys?
Well, yes - and if you don't think so, here's
why these terrifying creatures are worth avoiding
at all costs!
As if you need another reason to hate mosquitoes
- when they bite humans they can leave larvae
of the parasitic Filarial Worm.
These worms live and grow in our bodies, sometimes
taking years to mature into full adults, leaving
only inconspicuous rashes and sores.
Years later, they work together to block the
vessels of your lymphatic system, creating
a build-up of fluid and leading to diseases
like elephantiasis.
This is one of the leading causes of disability
in the world.
Another worm worth hating is the pinworm.
Pinworm eggs are often eaten because of contaminated
or dirty hands.
The eggs hatch and mature in your gut, at
which point the adult female exits the anus
to lay a new batch of eggs on the surrounding
skin.
Your butthole becomes a nest!
This causes intense itching, often leading
to re-contaminated hands or fingernails, which
can end up in your mouth again, restarting
the cycle.
Feel like scratching your bum?
Do yourself a favour and wash those hands
and fingernails!
On the other side of the body, live the lovely
pubic lice - sometimes called 'crabs'.
Though it's not uncommon to find these buggers
in your eyebrows, beard or even eyelashes.
The itching is from an allergic reaction to
their saliva, and it'll take treatment with
medication or shaving it all off to get rid
of them.
Of course, abstinence or no sex works well
as a preventative measure, along with not
sharing your undies with other people.
Some parasites are meant for marine animals,
but end up in humans out of the goodness of
our...gut?
The Anisakis Nematode infects humans after
eating raw or undercooked fish - like sushi
- which contains the larvae.
The worms penetrate our gut wall and cause
abdominal pain, nausea and even vomiting.
But, nobody really wins this one, as the nematode
can't mature in a human gut and eventually
dies.
The Tongue Biter is another marine parasite.
This tongue eating louse finds a suitable
fish and chews off it's tongue, only to cling
on to the stub in it's place.
Here they stay feeding on the fishes blood,
all the while mating and dispersing their
progeny into the ocean.
And finally, the wonderful cordyceps which
are fungi known for creating zombie ants.
The fungus takes over the ants body and mind,
making it leave the colony and begin climbing
upward to a more ideal temperature and humidity.
The ant then bites onto a stem or leaf and
gets locked into position until it dies.
At which point, the fungus bursts through
the ants head and spreads outward.
Could such a parasite ever affect humans?
For everyone's sake, we hope not!
Our friends at James Cook University helped
us put this horrifying list of parasites together,
with special help from parasitologist Dr Kate
Hutson.
JCU is one of the world's leading institutions
focusing on the tropics with an opportunity
to study in a diverse physical environment
unparalleled by any university in the world.
I actually studied there for a semester abroad!
If you want to learn more, be sure to head
over to their website jcu.edu.au - link in
the description!
You can check out the amazing Dr Kate Hutson
as well at marineparasites.com.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!